Hello, and welcome to "This Week
in Android Development"
for June 17, 2013.
My name is Reto Meier.
If it feels like it's been more
than a week since the
last "Week in Android
Development," you can blame
these three troublemakers who
flew in from the UK for Google
I/O. Between keeping them out of
trouble and preparing over
30 technical sessions for the
conference, our team has had
its hands full.
We've shipped them safely back
to London and also made the
I/O session videos available
for you to watch in the
comfort of your own home.
One of the biggest announcements
at I/O '13 was
Android Studio.
To help make the Android tools
the best tools, the Tools team
have created an Android
Developer Tools
community on Google+.
Join us to talk tools
with the Tools team.
Of course, it wouldn't be Google
I/O without the I/O
app, and the Android Design in
Action team have performed a
full teardown showing how it
was put together on last
week's show.
They also dove into building
sharing into your app and
creating immersive
full screen UIs.
For all the Chet Haase fans
out there, we've got more
"Chet Bytes." Last week's
episode explored animating
listview deletion.
Chet will be joining us in the
hot seat later this week for
the first episode of "DevBytes
Backstage." He'll be joining
us to answer all your animation
questions, so send
them in, or join us live on
Thursday via our Hangout.
Not to be outdone, Nick and
Roman will be answering your
design questions this Friday.
Last week, the App Clinic team
had the pleasure of joining
the Oslo Google Developers
group for our
second GDG App Clinic.
Oslo is beautiful this time of
year, or so they told us when
we connected over Hangouts.
Keep an eye out for the
video this Wednesday.
Also last week, we tried our
hand at teaching people
Android in person, hosting our
annual Android camp for 30 of
the brightest sophomores and
juniors from some of the top
universities in the country.
We'll be taking the show over
the pond in August to teach
Android to some of
the brightest
students not in this country.
We'll also be making these
instructor-led training
materials available for
download, so the same quality
Android education will soon
be available to everyone,
including mediocre students at
below average universities.
In the meantime, we're
publishing plenty of great
learning material on
developer.android.com, such as
the last week's release of the
Purchase Status API guide.
It was a big week in app
releases too, with BBC Weather
launching and quickly rocketing
to the top of the
Google Play UK charts.
It's a beautiful, pure Android
app, so it's no surprise to
see it do well.
It is currently available only
to users in the UK, but the
team is hard at work adding
support for forecasts that
aren't cloudy with
a chance of rain.
Developers using Google Play
Game Services have also been
hard at work, with "Jewels
2" becoming the first
cross-platform game to use
these new services.
That means you can compare your
jewel matching skills
with friends using all manner of
internet-connected rounded
corner rectangular devices.
"One Tap Hero" also launched an
upgrade this week that saw
it integrate leaderboards while
"What's This?" launched
support for Google+ sign-in,
leaderboards and achievements.
Coming up in "Android Developers
Live" this week,
we've got a new "BizDevByte"
from Shazia, who's introducing
Google Play for Education
and explaining
how you can get involved.
This week's App Clinic
will feature GDG
Vilnius from Lithuania.
There's nearly twice as many
mobile phones in Lithuania as
there are people, so it's no
surprise to see these guys are
passionate about Android
development.
You can track all of the
upcoming "Android Developers
Live" shows at developers.googl
e.com/live/android.
That's all for "This Week
in Android Development"
for June 17, 2013.
Join us for this week's "Android
Developers Live"
broadcasts, and remember,
we're up all
night for good fun.
We're up all night
to code Android.